[Musique]
elle est bien le mot sert à mieux donc
18 minutes
j'espère je vais vous parler de l'école
aujourd'hui et plus particulièrement de
l'école du futur
si vous allez sur un moteur de recherche
et que vous tapez école du futur vous
tomberez immanquablement sur cette image
c'est l'image d'une salle de classe où
le numérique est omniprésent les élèves
ont des ordinateurs des tablettes et
l'enseignant dispose d'un gigantesque
tableau numérique pour faire son cours
cette classe du futur elle arrive à
grands pas si l'on regarde les chiffres
dans les collèges le nombre
d'ordinateurs et de tablettes a été
multiplié par deux ce les dix dernières
années le nombre de tableaux numériques
quant à lui été multiplié par dix or si
l'on regarde les chiffres pisa on essaie
pisa le programme qui évalue les
performances des systèmes éducatifs et
bien sur cette même période de 10 ans on
se rend compte que les résultats
scolaires des collégiens français sont
en baisse tentant mathématiques qu'en
lecture ou en sciences
pourtant l'amérique change le monde
n'est ce pas la communication la santé
l'information
l'entreprise industries la vie de tous
les jours pourtant je crois bien me
souvenir que je voulais pas me trains a
fait une conférence ted qui est devenu
célèbre dans laquelle il a montré avec
brio qu'il suffisait de donner un
ordinateur avec une connexion internet
haut débit à des enfants livrés à
eux-mêmes pour qu'ils apprennent des
choses extraordinaires
alors je pose une question pourquoi le
numérique ne change t'il pas l'école
comme il change le monde pour répondre à
cette question je vais vous faire une
confidence quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière je me suis jeté à corps perdu
dans le numérique
j'ai exploré le numérique
j'ai vendu du numérique j'ai fait du
numérique et bien aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire en toute humilité que j'ai
fait fausse route
je me suis trompé et je vous expliquer
pourquoi
et pour comprendre pourquoi il va
falloir que l'on visite un petit peu le
passé de l'école voilà une photo qui a
été prise en 2013 c'est une classe qui
utilisent des tablettes numériques
il pourrait être intéressant de la
mettre en relation avec une photo plus
ancienne
et je vais vous montrer une photo que
tout le monde connaît qui a été prise
par doisneau en 1956 il ya 50 ans
d'écart entre ces deux photos c'est
étrange vous ne trouvez pas on a
l'impression qu'on a subtilisé les
ardoises des élèves de 1956 pour les
remplacer par des tablettes de 2013 et
que l'on ait fait cela sans rien changer
à la salle de classe la salle de classe
est un concept extraordinairement figé
regardez nous sommes en france en 1960
je vais mettre cette photo en
perspective avec une photo du japon une
photo actuelle
alors vous allez me dire que la faute du
japon ont fait plus moderne mais parce
qu'elle est en couleur donc j'ai tout
prévu
voilà
c'est la même salle de classe il ya 50
ans d'écart entre ces deux photos c'est
la même salle de classe des élèves qui
sont en rangée ainsi immobile et
silencieux et vous pouvez chercher non
pas maintenant que tout à l'heure où
chercher salles de classe et vous verrez
toujours les élèves ainsi immobile et
silencieux partout et quand je dis
partout c'est vraiment partout
même poudlard qui peut dire que jk
rowling quelqu'un qui n'a pas
d'imagination
si elle n'a pas ses d'imagination pour
imaginer la salle de classe différemment
la réalité c'est que nous manquons
totalement d'imagination lorsqu'il
s'agit de s'intéresser à l'éducation de
nos enfants
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui aux
salles de classe nos écoles sont des
lieux d'enfermement où les élèves
doivent rester ainsi immobile et
silencieux les heures durant c'est pas
vrai alors je commence à comprendre
pourquoi mes enfants quand il y avait
les rentrées scolaires avec la boule au
ventre ou la larme à l'oeil
il est évident que aller travailler dans
ces conditions
ça donne envie à personne mais notre
école à oublier deux choses qui sont
connexes à ce que je viens de vous dire
premièrement c'est le plaisir
d'apprendre
on a complètement ville puisse apprendre
deuxièmement c'est le corps de l'élève
on a beaucoup parlé du corps aujourd'hui
l'école aujourd'hui elle nie
complètement le corps des élèves
vous savez ce que c'est le corps de
l'élève dans le système éducatif
c'est ce qui sert à transporter la tête
de la maison à l'école et de l'école à
la maison c'est tout c'est un peu comme
si le corps rentrer en classe poser la
tête sur la table et disparaissez jusqu
à ce que la sonnerie 310 élèves n'est
pas qu'une tête même si j'ai connu
quelques tranches dans ma carrière mais
il a aussi encore on ne peut plus
continuer à nier complètement le corps
de l'élève
alors il ya une explication historique
tout cela et pour ce faire il faut
remonter en 1680 s'attaquant même 1680
nous avons jean baptiste de la salle qui
popularise dans ces écoles
l'enseignement simultanées c'est à dire
qu'il dit à partir de maintenant il y
aura un enseignant 1680 un enseignant
uniques détenteurs des savoirs
et cet enseignant va dispenser un même
cours un ensemble d'élèves d'un âge
rassembler dans un même lieu et pour
cela et uniquement pour cela il a créé
des salles avec des chaises des tables
et les élèves soient aussi immobile et
silencieux
un peu comme vous l'a maintenant parce
que c'est moi qui parle et que c'est
super intéressant les perturber pas
monter dicks mon idée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il est grand temps de
changer de pédagogie les temps changent
et le numérique bouleverse le monde
les élèves du 21e siècle non pas du tout
le même accès à l'information que les
élèves du 19e siècle
michel serres le dit même qu'ils n'ont
plus la même tête mais pour changer la
pédagogie il faut changer la sorte de
père salle de classe parce que rappelez
vous la salle de classe a été conçu pour
l'enseignement simultanées parce que les
lieux dans lesquels nous nous trouvons
conditionnent nos attitudes vous
observez quand vous êtes rentré qu'est
ce que vous avez fait vous êtes assis
sur les fauteuils il n'a pas un de vous
qui a dit olivier un chéri on va sur
scène on va se mettre à côté du rond
rouge
on va aller voir le speaker un peu plus
prégnant vous vous êtes assis sagement
comme vous l'auriez fait à l'école les
bons élèves devant
les bons élèves qui ont peur des
postillons speaker au deuxième rang et
puis à vous là bas au fond un côté du
radiateur ont marqué ce sont eux les
plus intelligents parce que quitte à
rester assis et mobiles pendant des
heures je pense qu'il vaut mieux être à
côté du radiateur
on ne pensait pas comme elle colle je
vous dis d'ailleurs cette situation être
ici devant vous ça me rappelle mon
premier jour de classe
je suis rentré j'ai fait entrer les
élèves ils se sont installés comme
voulant d'abord au chaud et puis après
progressivement devant parce qu'ils
aient plus de places
et puis j'ai dit bonjour pour la
personne n'a répondu
donc j'ai dit vous allez bien qu'il a je
crois qu'il ya une élève au premier rang
qu'un vaguement hocher de la tête ce que
j'ai interprétés comme étant oui ce à
quoi j'ai répondu moi c'est un lieu dans
40 ans
non j'adore mon métier j'adore mon
métier
en revanche je me suis un petit peu
lassé voyez ça fait 15 ans que je fais
des ted x devant mes élèves tous les
jours donc au bout d'un moment j'en ai
un peu assez et g challenge et mes
élèves je leur ai dit voilà je vous pose
un exercice je vais vous demander des
élèves de terminale de réfléchir à ce
que doit être l'aménagement de la salle
de classe
je suis parti en quittant la salle je me
suis dit la semaine prochaine ils auront
oublié la semaine prochaine la semaine
suivante n'avait pas oublié c'est moi
qui avais oublié eux ils sont arrivés un
camp plan un plan de la salle de classe
les élèves ne sont pas les architectes
le plan n'était pas à l'échelle donc on
n'a pas pu le mettre en avant
les choses auraient pu en rester là
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont pris la
règle jaune tout le monde la connaît la
règle jaune tout le monde l'a connu
alliée et dans les salles de classe -
depuis la troisième république
elle y est encore eh bien ils ont mesuré
les tables les chaises et la salle de
classe et ils ont fait un autre plan
cette fois ci à l'échelle des petits
carrés représenter les tables et les
tables on les agences et à l'envi et
donc du coup mais elles ont décidé
dorénavant bien celle de classe ce sera
ça et ça a été ça on a fait début parce
que les élèves ont dit nous on a envie
de coopérer de collaborer alors bien
évidemment si les enseignants parmi vous
il ya rien d'exceptionnel à mettre des
tables ont eu c'est pas avec ça que je
vais avoir le prix nobel de pédagogie
d'ailleurs il n'y en a pas
ça ne pouvait pas y en avoir j'imagine
mal le jeune alfred qui plus tard à
l'inventer la dynamite être du genre à
être ainsi calme
immobile et silencieux non ce qui est
exceptionnel c'est que c'était la
première fois dans la vie de ses élèves
qu'un enseignant leur disais à les y
réfléchissez à l'espace dans lequel vous
allez évoluer et ça ça les a intéressés
et donc du coup ils ont investi
ils ont commencé à collaborer plus ça
allait moins je parlais moi je parlais
plus ils travaillent et les choses
auraient pu là aussi en rester là
puis un jour j'ai un groupe d'élèves qui
vient me voir pour me dire monsieur
qu'on aimerait se déplacer qui se
déplace et voulait aller où on voudrait
juste utiliser votre tableau avec un b
majuscule puisqu'ils avaient coûté
alessi utiliser mon tableau et donc les
élèves sont allés au tableau et ils ont
commencé à s'expliquer le court au
tableau alors au début un groupe fils de
groupe g après tout le monde voulait
aller au tableau c'est assez étonnant
comme les élèves peuvent aimer aller au
tableau quand c'est pas l'enseignant qui
leur demande très rapidement c'était
vraiment l'objet de convoitise de sept
salles de classe ont été bloqués donc
j'ai fait quelque chose d'un petit peu
fou j'ai dit aux et là vous prenez la
règle jaunes et les caps on a les quais
rossi et vous allez tracées sur les murs
de la salle de classe des tableaux il ya
un petit moment de flottement et puis
très vite le côté transgressif de la
chose a fait qu'ils ont tracé des
tableaux sur les murs et on a commencé à
écrire sur les murs j'avais
établissement est un peu surpris
et très rapidement il en sortit la carte
bleue et donc la salle de classe est
devenu comme ceci est mon cours est
devenu comme cela et là je me suis dit
voilà et c'est pour ça que j'ai ce
métier c'est pour ça c'est pour voir des
élèves qui bougent leurs corps leurs
esprits des élèves qui vont discuter
collaborer argumenté les uns avec les
autres
des élèves vivant quand il fait ses
élèves maison retrouver quelque chose
d'essentiel que je citais tout à l'heure
c'est le plaisir d'apprendre d'un
évidemment alors le numérique me direz
vous j'ai complètement bien le numérique
je m'étais tellement focalisés sur
l'espace et sur la pédagogie que j'ai
complètement oublié le numérique
mais une fois que la salle de classe
était modifiée une fois que la pédagogie
était modifiée eh bien le numérique est
sorti comme le loup sort du bois
sans crier gare et il est sorti des
cartables des élèves leur smartphone
bien évidemment leur smartphone leur ont
servi à prendre en photo les tableaux à
regarder des vidéos à chercher des
ressources qu'ils s'échangeaient
immédiatement dans la classe sur leurs
réseaux le smartphone est un allié
essentiel pour l'enseignant fait un test
un jour pendant une classe de 30 élèves
et vous demander de lever la main celui
qui a oublié ça règle sa trousse son sac
ou alors sont douze ans son cahier son
classeur sa tête
vous aurez toujours une main levée
demandé une classe qui a oublié son
smartphone
c'est impossible règle numéro 1 un élève
n'oublie jamais son smartphone
l'élève il arrive devant le lycée il a
passé un smartphone il rentre en courant
et il bat le record du 100 m au passage
j'ai jamais vu faire ça pour un livre
alliés numéro un alors non je n'aurais
pas le prix nobel démagogie parce que
pour être honnête je n'ai rien inventé
nous n'avons rien inventé
nous n'avons fait que remettre au goût
du jour une pédagogie qui est très
ancien et qui s'appelle l'enseignement
mutuelle l'enseignement mutuelle était
une méthode d'enseignement qui a été
très utilisé au 19e siècle qui
consistait à faire des élèves les plus
âgés ou les plus avancés dans les
apprentissages des pivots de
l'enseignement ce sont ces élèves là les
moniteurs qui allait expliquer aux
élèves plus jeunes moins avancés les
lieux était différent la salle de classe
des différentes
les élèves pouvaient circuler ou aller
sur les tableaux pour s'expliquer le
court c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé mon
expérience l'expérience de la classe
mutuelle il faut savoir qu'il ya eu une
guerre scolaire terrible en france au
19e siècle entre l'enseignement mutuelle
et l'enseignant simultanée de jean
baptiste de la salle
il faut savoir que les politiques de
l'école ont choisi l'enseignement
simultanée pas parce que on apprenait
mieux c'était connu que on apprenait
deux fois plus vite à l'enseignement
mutuelle non ce sont des raisons
politiques et religieuses qui ont fait
que l'école est devenue ce qu'elle est
et si aujourd'hui vous êtes assez mobile
silencieux c'est parce que nous sommes
sous cheissoux des racines chrétiennes
et aujourd'hui on va à l'école
comment vont à la messe ça c'est la
réalité
alors nous avons ici deux méthodes
d'enseignement très honnêtement ce n'est
pas l'âge d'une méthode qui fait sa
pertinence son actualité ou 7 18 études
non ce qui compte c'est que cette
méthode danser
man soit en adéquation avec le monde
dans lequel les et je le reconnai
volontier la méthode d'enseignement
simultanée de jean baptiste de la salle
était en adéquation avec le monde tel
qu'il était au 19e siècle
c'est à dire un monde où l'information
était rare où la parole était porté par
le maître seul et unique détenteur de
savoir nous sommes en 2018
les choses ont changé et je reste
aujourd'hui persuadé que l'enseignement
mutuel selon moi est une méthode
d'enseignement beaucoup plus proche du
monde tel qu'il est aujourd'hui beaucoup
beaucoup plus proche de ce qu'est
l'intérêt des élèves de ce qu'est leur
culture alors si nous changeons un
salles de classe aux changements la
pédagogie si nous changeons la pédagogie
alors peut-être que l'école s'inscrira
enfin dans son temps et je peux vous
assurer que très rapidement les élèves
retrouveront la chose la plus importante
le plaisir va pendre jonas
[Applaudissements]